PAIGE BAILEY: Hi.
I'm Paige from the
TensorFlow team.
And you may have heard
that on March 6 and 7
we're hosting the
TensorFlow Dev Summit live,
in person and online.
We're bringing together
a mix of machine
learning users from around the
world for two days of highly
technical talks, demos,
and conversations
with the TensorFlow
team and our community.
The keynote address and
lots of the top sessions
will be live streamed
on TensorFlow.org.
So be sure to head there
now to sign up for updates.
And since TensorFlow is
all about open source
collaboration, we
want to hear from you.
Send us your
TensorFlow questions
now with the hashtag
Ask TensorFlow.
And I'll be there with my
co-host Laurence Moroney
to answer as many as we can
during the live stream on March
6.
See you there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]